it actually has been really nice you
know we had a little bit of rain around
yesterday at this hour but skies look
completely different this morning we
finished the day yesterday with sunshine
and low 90s we're still a little humid
though you know we haven't had anything
to kind of sweep all the moisture out of
the air so we're stuck with dew points
right now in the upper 50's 52 percent
humidity 70's feel good and boy if the
drier if the air was dry they would feel
fantastic doesn't quite feel like fall
yet for us sunrise was 6 13 and sunset
706 but we're going to get a drier
influence this afternoon as we get some
southwest breezes and that's going to
help dry the air out so we should feel
better i think in 24 hours we'll notice
a big difference mid 70s boulder city
and mesquite this morning we're still 80
in laughlin kingman in the mid 60's and
up in cedar city it's a little cooler at
56 mid 50s up in ely this morning cali
any at 57 indian springs at 67 and look
at those 40s up in reno this jacket
weather up there now that's a taste of
fall but they also are still choked with
all of that wildfire smoke from the
caldor fire the dixie fire there's still
so many fires 15 active fires now in
northern california so still the smoke
forecast showing all the concentrations
with that air quality index over 500 at
times up around reno the monsoon
moisture is actually being pushed east
with showers in the plains right now and
over the northeast again epic flooding
across the northeast last night more
than nine inches of rain along with
tornadoes i'm talking about new york new
jersey maryland all these areas
pennsylvania all reeling from all that
flooding with flood warnings still in
place we got some video from maryland it
was actually a school bus with about 10
kids on it that was stuck in the
flooding and they had to be rescued you
can see the high running water there
there were so many stranded motorists
yesterday through the evening commute
and some of even the bigger metropolitan
areas but this was a little smaller area
of maryland but they did safely get all
the kids off the school bus yesterday
afternoon so thank goodness for that
unfortunately there were also some very
serious twisters
spun out by the leftovers of ida a
couple of people have been killed now in
the tornadoes in different areas that
one again in maryland but look at the
damage electricity out power lines down
buildings have been torn up and again
the flooding damage in places like new
york queens is just really phenomenal
there's so much cleanup has to be done
there ida over the course of what four
and a half days has done horrific damage
from louisiana to new england the cal
door fire 208 000 acres now evacuations
are working their way up the west side
of lake tahoe
so many people that have been told to
leave their homes will get drier and
breezier as the day goes on and you can
see all across the west it looks pretty
clear good news is red flag warnings
have now expired for the lake tahoe area
so they're not looking for those dry
erratic winds pushing the fire around 98
degrees for us this afternoon should
feel pretty good as those southwest
breezes set up we'll get hotter into the
weekend so the unofficial end of summer
looks pretty hot to me 105 by labor day
monday wow we'll keep triple digits into
early next week